The Alabama special election
between Roy Moore
and Doug Jones was last night.
It's a small, unimportant,
local election...
that we haven't really been
talking about that much.
The fake news, MSM and...
all media
are claiming a victory
for the Democrat, Doug Jones.
Just-just because
it's "technically" over.
But the truth is
this race is still...
it still feels
too close to call.
When the vote is this close,
then it's not over.
I had a feeling
he wasn't gonna concede,
because it just...
the numbers aren't adding up.
That's what we've got to do,
is wait on God
and let this process play out.
Yes! You go, Roy!
God takes his time.
It took him two days
to build the earth.
He spent the other five days
building America.
Drawing congressional districts
is surprisingly difficult.
But it's fine.
This is not a loss.
I mean, even in the extreme
long shot of Doug Jones
somehow winning, he has to face
another election in two years.
He's already a lame duck,
which is the exact thing
that Roy Moore hunts with his
extremely alpha micro-gun.
So... just to sum up,
the results of this election
are totally non-conclusive.
They barely even matter, anyway.
(short chuckle)
And I am in no way concerned
about what this means
for the future of the populist
Trump revolution.
Well, nothing much left
to talk about.
The fight continues after this.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)
Mother(bleep)!
Damn it! Damn it!
Bring it in here!
Get back in here, Chuck!
Quick, quick, quick!
Guys...
what the (bleep)
happened last night?
Look behind you--
do you see a liberal?
Good, we lost 'em.
This-- right here, this--
is just between us.
-Shh.
-KLEPPER (grunts): Oh.
Guys, we lost, and I hate it.
In Alabama,
Alabama went to a Democrat.
Are you (bleep) kidding me?
The reddest state.
They're so red
they only recently
started using the pronoun "she."
It doesn't make sense.
I can't...
I can't wrap my head around it.
How did this guy--
the guy that I,
Steve Bannon,
and the president
got behind-- lose?
Did we back the wrong guy?
Do we take a moment and really
analyze the type of person
we're hitching our wagon to?
No.
I don't have time for that.
It can't be our fault.
The blame has to lie elsewhere.
Someone cost Roy Moore
this election.
But whom?
Or, even worse,
who?
God gave me ten blame-casters,
and it's time
to finger some bad guys.
Suspect number one,
Steve Bannon.
Steve Bannon, the president's
chief political adviser
during the campaign,
was wrong.
REPORTER:
"After Alabama disaster
GOP must do right thing
and dump Steve Bannon."
This guy does not belong
on the national stage.
He looks like
some disheveled drunk.
People at the White House were
using words like "devastating."
And also suggesting the
president has egg on his face
because of his former adviser,
Steve Bannon.
What? The president does not
have egg on his face.
It's Egg McMuffin.
And it's technically
on his neck.
Steve Bannon engineered
Roy Moore's candidacy.
But blaming Bannon is too easy.
He's the only person
we know is innocent.
It's never the obvious suspect.
Haven't you seen
a Shyamalan movie?
Bannon's been dead
this whole time.
I mean, just look at him.
Yeah.
Plus, Breitbart's
front page reports
"Bannon Least Culpable!"
You can trust that,
because that Web site
is run by Steve Bannon himself.
So... so, who sabotaged
Roy Moore?
Next suspect, the swamp.
A very senior GOP source
on the Hill
thinks that
this is Mitch McConnell's fault.
Both Paul Ryan
and Mitch McConnell
are major problems
for the president.
REPORTER: Republican Senator
Jeff Flake of Arizona
sent this $100 check
to Moore's Democratic opponent
Doug Jones,
writing on the memo line
of the check,
"Country over party."
Oh.
Country over party is not only
a dangerous 1700s sex position--
it's also a rallying cry
for wimpy moderates like Flake.
Next suspect to blame for
Roy Moore's loss, Horse Twitter.
Now, now,
Roy Moore rode a horse
to his polling place,
which is standard.
And the mean world
of the Internet,
specifically the horse Internet,
decided to go all in on him,
saying that his form sucks
and any horse person can see
he's a fake cowboy.
You know what,
maybe I'm overthinking it.
Maybe this is just a referendum
on Trump.
Wrong. I never overthink.
I am an underthinker.
Am I right, Fox?
This was not a referendum
on Trump.
I feel like it was a referendum
on Harvey Wein-stein...
-Weinstein.
-Ah. Oh, okay. Oh.
Okay, so that's
the alleged predator
everyone's been talking about.
Weinstein must have forced
his way
into the Alabama election
without its consent
and activated a cabal
of silence-breaking women
who mistakenly voted
against Roy Moore.
But how could women keep
Roy Moore out of the Senate?
I mean, it's not a mall.
You know what,
I think I found
the prime suspect,
a secret group
that wields great power
and hides in plain sight,
who works specifically on behalf
of mainstream Democrats
to steal elections
and daytime talk shows.
REPORTER:
Black women, Jones won 98-2.
It was black women that, uh, put
Doug Jones over the hump.
This victory was delivered to us
by black women.
That's it.
I know who sabotaged
Roy Moore's Senate campaign.
Black women.
In fact,
98% of black Alabama women
voted against Roy Moore
last night.
-(cheering and applause)
-We're all shocked.
We're shocked.
They colluded to take him down.
This is voter suppression.
They voted
to suppress Roy Moore.
This was a stinging rebuke
by black voters
to someone who really would've
turned the clock back
a hundred years in Alabama.
That's not fair. No, no.
Roy Moore didn't want to turn
the clock back a hundred years--
that is slander.
He specifically said
that the last time America
was great was during slavery,
which was at least
200 years ago.
Who looks stupid now?
Opposers, I've stumbled
onto something big here.
Black women came together
for Obama, against Trump.
And this Me Too movement
that targets
innocent tiny cowboys
like Roy Moore,
Google it--
scratch that, Bing it--
a black woman started that, too.
Yeah, 20 years ago.
Her name is Tarana Burke.
And, here, I've been angrily
tweeting at Alyssa Milano
and Rose McGowan.
I mean, I take it back.
Charmed was a fine TV series
with adequate special effects.
Let's move on.
So, when it comes to what
happened in Alabama last night,
this much is clear:
powerful, organized black women
are coming for us,
and we need to be prepared.
We need hard-core recon
to investigate
this emerging threat.
But it will be challenging.
There is surprisingly
little mainstream literature,
TV or films about them,
like, at all.
And, also, they don't live
in my neighborhood,
because
my congressional district
is shaped
like a spaghetti noodle.
But here's the plan.
If conservatives want
to retain power,
we need to find out
how black women managed
this political coup,
find out what they want
and what they don't want.
Maybe I'll embed on one
of those girls trips
I've heard so much about.
I'm going to wiretap
the movement.
I'm going to use all
of my surveillance.
Because if we want to make
America great again,
we need to listen
to black women.